good morning everyone and welcome to the
first ever episode of the developers
strike back this is the opportunity for
all of the developers who we gave candid
feedback to during the estimation Friday
and whose design skills we tore apart on
Android design in action just this glass
Tuesday to tell us exactly what they
think about what we told them my name is
greater I'm en now joining us today are
for developers not in the studio because
I was able to file a restraining order
in time but live via Google+ Hangout and
who are the developers today riddle we
have a we have a bunch of guys so we've
got mateus from yoga timer we have
colors from timer alarm stopwatch and
clock and that's right everyone i am
reading this off a piece of paper in
front of me impetus developer Harry aura
aha and hybrid is a hybrid timer hybrid
stopwatch but Javier sell mana so yeah
thank you guys for joining we're going
to bring each of them up on screen as we
go through each of the apps and give
them a chance to tell us exactly what
they think of us I think before we get
started we should remind everyone of
exactly what we were telling these guys
they should be doing last Friday and so
that's the prescriptions for great timer
or stopwatch apps so again and these are
things which which I think you guys are
familiar with you know it's not
contradicting the design guide having as
much functionality as possible rich
notifications which really turned out to
be a differentiator for a lot of the
apps i think and keeping it simple so as
we as we mentioned before hand these are
the apps which we are going to check out
now you skip to use a service but i
think that's because we when we talked
about it it really using notifications
and my as a service anyway exactly so we
could tell that just from from the fact
that everyone was so it was using
notifications one way or the other so
let's let's see if we can spend a couple
of minutes introducing the other folks
so if you want to try and bring everyone
up one
time there we've also got Roman I forgot
women hey Roman so Romans going to a
stand-in for the Android design in
action team and and take all of the
constructive feedback that the
developers have around the redesigns
which you guys did now do we have the
beautiful marks that we do we have the
beautiful boxer which we will put up
before we talk about a chap so we're
going to we're going to put each figure
eyes up on screen colors so this is
carlos you want to introduce yourself
briefly tell us which after you're
responsible for the air put a catalyst
from Barcelona I work on a company that
was in developing traveler former wives
eos on android and every we stay in that
review very cool so we really liked your
appt time alarm stopwatch and clock was
one of the fabrics so i will will to
check on you like your city to although
it's all sort of a blur to me after mwc
yeah we were a regular visitors to a
buffalo yeah yeah cool alright so this
is a re for my impetus yes how do toho
from finland hello everybody and i'm a
professional java developer in a company
called soul eater and and I'm a surfer
Android ha Beast by night awesome
awesome I think how a lot of us got
started with Android is outside of our
day job so oh yeah that's cool thanks
for joining us thank you this is xavier
e i'll be translating for him ah Xavier
and producer daniel is going to be a
translating for Xavier so this is a
developer of a hybrid stopwatch next up
is Matthias Matthias this is another
another friend from the Nordics a
developer of a yoga timer
I think you'll need a muted that's right
again thank you and so yeah I dropped in
that joke time around for sweetness is
dead Vince Geneva and also professional
java developer public all concepts and
we like to do hundred stuff during my
free time very cool it seems like a lot
of job and developers up in the Nordics
I wonder under what that could be so as
it happens we're we're going to start
off with yoga timer so let's let's talk
a little bit out that app so can you
maybe tell
as well I'm just
you
hmm oh yeah as you mentioned you have
the buttons on on the bottom as well
that's kind of hard to unsay to Radley
some other apps are actually doing
something nice where they don't show the
ads the first few days so you get used
to that and feel of that it's actually
interesting tremors I mean one thing
that you may want to consider doing and
I don't know how many developers have
sort of tried something like this but
not something I would be interesting is
to actually have some a be testing of
your app in the wild so that you can
basically randomly decide between one or
two different alternative ads and then
try and measure the the click-through
rate and and the effectiveness to see
whether you know are you getting more ad
impressions are you getting people who
continue using the app more or less
based on where those ads go and it might
be interesting to see what some of the
best alternatives are absolutely
different but you know there's a pull
quote that I'm going to take from from
all of that is Matias was able to put
together a completely design guide
compliant app when he was under the gun
very true yeah so what two balls got a
little nice resources and we have a
couple of nice guys over at the Google+
and we have the community their Android
niceties jahani and after UI patterns
and ruin I mean you guys there's a lot
of resource out there sweet thank you
for the compliments here I your free
gift will be in the man yeah very timely
we're we're up for review this quarter
perfect so uh you know we've only got
the the shortest shows that I still
we're going to move along to our to the
next step but thank you very much for
joining us stick around hopefully we'll
have a few minutes to the end and and we
can bring everyone back together but
thank you for the thank you for the app
endure and for coming on the show
I think Roman has a calm anyone's ad far
away room yeah one super quick common
since you guys are talking about kind of
first time used so you know design
guidelines we have a section on help
providing help but I also want to call
this a third-party library called a
showcase of you on github it has the
kind of like circle e blue thing that
can highlight a specific UI element
mm-hmm the highlight of qi o minute that
I'm that you want to kind of drive
people towards that may help that's
what's called a so without using the
same sort of you why as the first time
you start Android and you get the little
nap when you hit the launcher for the
first time that sort of thing yeah very
cool very cool yeah so Roman make sure
you include a link on the on the event
page so people can find that easily
excellent so we're going to move on now
to to our next step which is timer
laughs stop watching clock breyer Carlos
Carlos covers all the bases absolutely
so absolutely nails the the various
things that we said so we're going to
quickly put up the the prescriptions
that we had go through that first so
yeah design guidelines we gave a tick
timer stopwatch so I think the concerns
here we had around the rich
notifications which weren't as rich as
as some of the other apps and I think we
were not entirely convinced that it was
using a service in the right way I think
for the stopwatch there was no
notification for stop watch which
implied no ongoing notification so you
want to tell us a little bit about the
app before we get too stuck into the
review yes I years ago a few years ago
and the lamp RP I mean to load some
tiles from the lamb I was too would I
have to wait two seconds from getting
back and I start to make my fixed up
calm down very nice it's a beautiful
anymore yeah and to learn more but I
start developing more and more and it is
my final person
Dirk whom now
you
you get on over time all right we're
going to we're going to jump ahead to
the next step that just being conscious
of time so thank you very much for for
joining us today and then stick around
and hopefully we can I have another chat
at the end but yeah thanks and
congratulations on a greater okay thank
you all right so we're going to move on
now to one of the two apps that got
reviewed during the fryer not the friday
the two third Tuesday Android design in
action show struggling with my words
today in it must be because we're doing
a show earlier than we usually do I
don't really get started before midday
yep you haven't had enough coffee no
have no alcohol no I have not enough of
anything so this is this is impotent
work on that we really do and this is
from re who we have on screen at the
moment so hi thank you for joining us
you want to tell us a little bit about
yourself in about the app okay thank you
for having me so uh impetus it came from
I'm i have been doing a lot of interval
training myself for a couple of years
three years maybe and there were already
a lot of timers for this sort of
specialized but they didn't have all the
stuff i need it so they didn't work
reliably they had poor sort of audio or
visual cues and they the sort of timing
engines didn't have serve all the stuff
i wanted to have because i wanted to do
sort of more complex workouts but they
need that they could do so this is sort
of from my own own need and then I just
wanted to publish it and see if somebody
else wants to have it so uh what I aim
for was earth you have to have a really
clear display because when doing
interval training you're going to be
sort of exhausted and you can't see sort
of five meters ahead of you so yeah so
you have to have big numbers and stuff
like that yeah we can say that on the
screen you got the big bowls you know
bright white numbers switched a cup you
know a big part of the screen so that's
yeah it's interesting and then I wanted
to have a landscape mode because most
didn't have it so I
dedicated view for that so it sort of
changes two different buttons and
whatever whatever and and then they we
address your up the landscape mode when
we look at it during the show that's
it's definitely idea yeah then the
timing mechanics I wanted to have a
timer that you can use if you just want
to have a really simple workout or if
you really want to go wild with
something really weird so there's an to
edit mode so you can have a basic that
you looked at so there's a sort of a
really normal work and rest and whatever
and rounds and then you have another
server mr. Hyde you just met the doctor
Jekyll there's a sort of mr. Hyde there
so there's the advanced mode where you
can surf there's a drag-and-drop
interface and whatever it's a surfer
tree structure and with loops and stuff
like that it's pretty far out there so I
sort of wanted to push the limit of what
the interval timer can do so you can
have a really many sets there you can
have like you said in the app clinic
that you can have have pyramids where
the time mr. of alternating and stuff
like that so it's pretty advanced
interesting so i think it's interesting
i think one of the challenges for the
Advanced Mode we're sort of playing with
it on a screen that you can't see just
to see sort of what you're talking about
any writer it looks like there's there's
quite an advanced set of things that you
can do it i think and maybe this is
because neither in nor i do this kind of
interval training I don't want to speak
for you in is this what you were just a
zero off to do everything not in this
manner now not on this matter so I think
the fact that neither is particularly
experienced with this makes it a little
bit harder to to understand but I think
the work flow around the advanced sort
of view could be a little bit more
intuitive it
so it doesn't give me a lot of help if I
don't already know what I'm trying to do
and if this is a nephew designed for
yourself that makes perfect sense right
because you just build the workflow that
makes sense to you yeah or if it depends
on the person some some people who have
said that they don't really understand
anything so that's true but many people
have said that yeah this is this really
the way to do it that they can sir yeah
make their way around it I think I'm
getting a hang of this yeah I don't
think this is a bad interface at all you
know actually what it reminds me a lot
of maybe because I've been doing so much
in as the adobe tools you know where you
move things into layers and such so yeah
I think there's some see it does that
make sense yeah well we're playing with
it just just off your camera I think the
people watching on YouTube broadcast can
see but yeah it's sort of once you've
added a few things it starts to make a
lot of sense yeah I think for for
something that says complex is this it's
hard to see how it could get one better
I think maybe you know an easier way to
add rounds for instance you know one
thing that I've appreciated about some
programs like this is that if you just
drag things to the left or to the right
it will sort of infer you know okay
you're dragging it to the right that
means you want it to be part of a set or
around her like that yeah yeah okay
that's cool that's interesting I'm just
going to bring up real quick the the
tips that we had so I think one of the
things here was we commented that it
didn't have the really rich
notifications that some of the design
elements were a little bit off from what
the design guide says yeah and the fact
that it lacked the stopwatch functions
as well frankly I think you know given
what you've described as the purpose for
the app I think it kind of makes sense
why there isn't a stopwatch there to
begin with but I think again based on
money and was saying earlier it's it's
kind of a piece of functionality you may
want to have while you're doing this
sort of exercise as well so let me let
me give you an example and this may be
unique to the way that I work out but
sometimes I'll be working out you know
in some sort of timed manner
and then I'm just you know I'm feeling
really good i want to just keep going
and so what i want is at the very least
I want the timer to count down past zero
so I going yeah that makes sense that
makes sense it means that something that
you know you're interested in doing do
you want do you know are you dead pretty
clear is it just that I'm not nearly as
disciplined maybe that's what you need
less stuff watches and more discipline
there you go well what are your thoughts
you know is it a piece of functionality
you'd consider putting in or is that
unity online sort of outside the scope
of what you're trying to build probably
not not as a sort of dedicated feature
because yeah it's out of the scope but
they're sort of East a stopwatch there
you just have to have to know it because
in the indie if you're using there's a
sort of a log it there that you you can
add there you can go to the preferences
and you can add a third button there
actually which is this orifice keep
button and you can use a log that when
you when you punch the skip button it's
going to record the time that was
elapsed is that point good and then you
in the end you can have a sort of run
down that you took 15 seconds on the
first interval then you took 25 and so
on so it is there but it's sure it's not
obvious it's a little bit yeah well see
you also have I shake to skip and shake
to start which i think is really cool
that sounds super useful for a workout
um yeah unless you're enhancers and
lucky well yeah but I it yeah this is
this is a perennial problem with with
all well all applications in general
mobile apps especially is you know how
would I have found that unless i was
browsing through the settings menu which
a lot of people don't do that's true
they probably I I think that Romans
advice to use the I'm sorry what was the
library called again showcased you yeah
showcase for you might help you know or
a few I don't know I hesitate to use the
word toast but maybe something that pops
up you know when you take an action like
starting um it's kind of a did you know
you can also do this a different way
effect I mean and this would be
interested to see what what you guys
think of this but one alternative might
be to enable something like shake skip
and shake start to begin with but the
first time that it detects you're doing
that rather than doing the action it
says hey shaking it like this is going
to automatically start do you want to
start or disable this action so you're
sort of opting people in be giving them
some warning as to what the hell is
going on sure and something yeah with I
think we saw some of our music players
did that right absolutely shake to
randomize yeah ok so we're rapidly
running out of time but I did want to
pop up on on screen so we're looking at
the at the redesign that that Roman Nick
and Adam did on Tuesday did you get a
chance to have a look at their readathon
what did you think of the suggestions
they had yeah I did and of course it's
really beautiful to compare to what I
have because they know this stuff so
there may be the problem is that it's
sort of out of context of course because
they they probably be in sort of looking
at the my sort of basic version i would
say that you're looking at the Jekyll
version for sure mmhmm yeah so sort of a
sort of putting it into my appt sort of
takes maybe a bit more work because you
have to think about what it does to the
advanced site absolutely under I think
it would be relatively straightforward
to put the the simple case in but you're
right you want to keep that same look
and feel and functionality across the
entire suite and I think there's really
a lot more to it than that so yeah is do
you think it might be a direction that
you'll slowly try and head down yes
probably because cool i really have to
it's true that it it it's it's pretty
difficult for somebody to start using
this sort of fresh out of when you load
it up it doesn't really say much what
you have to do is pretty professional
sort of speech so it would certainly
help yeah i think that's you know the
big challenge right is that i think most
of us because we tend to be pretty keen
on writing code to solve problems right
you have something that you need done so
you write an app to
take care of that and then you can could
put it on google play really easy and to
see if there's anyone else who finds it
useful and it's kind of not until you
get to that certain level of popularity
that you like actually you know maybe I
should turn this into something that
anyone can use and then it can be real
it can be real challenged takes a lot of
it also is finding your audience because
especially when you're in a crowded
field like this I you know I know every
time I've gone looking for an app to
suit a specific purpose and I know I'm
not the only one that does this I'll
download five or ten abs hmm and check
them out really quickly and so there's
some things in this app where I'm
thinking wow I this is exactly the
feature that I wanted but I didn't even
realize it exists and I think that's
really the challenge for trying to
monetize your apps in Google Play is to
convert people that need what you're
selling and want exactly what you offer
but don't realize that you're the guy
that's going to give it to them
absolutely it's that you have like that
1020 seconds when they first load the
app to convince them that this is the
app that you need stop looking at
everything else and that's that's a real
challenge yeah cool well thank you very
much for joining again we're kind of out
of time but I do want to spend a couple
of minutes on hybrid as well but yeah
thnkx thanks for joining us and thanks
for yeah like a great app and throws are
showing us the UM the the doctor the mr.
Hyde version as well it's definitely
some interesting is really cool i like
it a lot nicely done thank you okay so
the next up we're going to have a look
at is the hybrid stopwatch and timer by
Javier who I think is not entirely
comfortable speaking to us on camera but
we're going to put you on camera and
have have Daniel read out anything that
you type to us so if you want to give
this a brief written description tell us
a little bit about yourself in the app
will have Daniel read it out for us okay
so he actually has a description
me go back up excellent eighty guys
javiera Simona from from Chile he's a
graphic designer on he said of all
private stopwatch and timer and he's
really happy to be here today with us
sweet we're really happy to have you
this is out of a designer you see
there's a lot of questions so this was
the app which had an incredible feature
graphic great icon you open it up it has
a very distinctive definitive look and
feel it's something which in of all the
apps that we had to look at this was the
one I was most looking forward to so it
really passes Ian's test of you know I
download half a dozen which is the one
that I'm most likely to use was the one
which leaves the impression so well done
on a great-looking app you know I think
given the fact that you're a designer
and we have a limited time I think we
should skip straight to the mocks and
put them on screen and I think Roman you
actually were the one which messed with
this graphic designers wonderful work
with an alternative suggestion so why
don't we start by having a Roman justify
way to London to yourself Roman end and
would give Javier a chance at the same
time to maybe type down what you think
of what Roman has done to your beautiful
work so um in the marks i mean i think
that it's pretty clear that we just
tried a different direction right um
there's there's really mean nothing
fundamentally wrong with creating an app
that uses the skeuomorphism i mean it
it's totally if you want to make an
applica that's totally your call it's
your application we just kind of thought
you know what if we were to take these
features the same set of features the
same kind of identity of the app and
apply some of the holo styling I think
what we tried to do is you know say like
what would this make it feel more
Android you would it make kind of users
that have you know newer devices God's
Nexus and so on would it make them feel
like this actually is an app that's
better that belongs more we don't really
know right i mean these are just mucks
so this is this is not saying you know
my god you should definitely follow this
direction this is kind of a what if
scenario Wow but I think fundamentally
I'm the one thing I did want to
point out was just the navigation so the
one could the non-visual concern was
navigation was in the menu button in the
legacy menu button and that just it's
kind of difficult I think that it's it's
difficult to discover for users and it's
a it's kind of like a mosh ponch of
navigation and actions and so in the
redesign that I did what's probably more
important than the the visual language
change was just the be bringing up the
navigation more forward and an
immediately up front for the users so
the ability to toggle between a
stopwatch enough at a timer and the
ability to swipe very quickly between
laps and and the current stopwatch
valued oh it so they agree i think
that's one of the big improvements i
think you know in terms of the actual
look of the timer itself i think you
know that could definitely go either way
i quite like Romans redesigning that it
looks like something which would ship
with the phone if we had a time or a
stopwatch built-in I reckon it would
look a lot like that although it would
probably be blue rather than orange yeah
that's just for the feet just to
accentuate that you can still theme
right i mean the the official app it has
awesome themes you know green blue pink
orange which is really awesome great way
to customize really simple way to
customize and so you can do the same
thing with hollow i would love to see
your take Roman on the redesign of the
skeuomorphic design to be more in line
with the navigation you're talking about
because I completely agree with your
analysis the navigation I also think
that you know looking of course we're
looking at the the initial screen on the
left here and then on the right we're
looking at that's the laps right I and I
I greatly prefer Romans redesign of that
screen I felt like the original screen
had too much information compacted into
too small an area and you know that one
of my pet peeves is repeating gradient
designs or lists I'm I feel like that up
a lot yeah that ship has sailed I feel
the same way about the gradients on the
top of the the left hand screen
were these these sort of like uh um you
know pipe effect yeah i think is feel
feels just a little oil it feels less
designed than the main clock which looks
amazing it uses gradients to give a very
realistic lighting effect on what looks
like a beautiful you know timepiece oh
absolutely I would love a stopwatch
which look like that now I can have her
there you go yeah so I think you know
from my perspective I I'd kind of like
to see like I agree again with the
navigation i think is much simpler the
discoverability of the stopwatch and
timer in the laps and so on from the
original design is suboptimal I think
but having that beautiful skeuomorphic
design placed in sort of the container
that Roman suggested I think would be a
really nice sort of compromise so what
do you think havia you know is does the
air as the navigation alternative the
Romans suggested sort of makes sense to
you is it a direction that you know
think you may want a head or are you
just really happy with the way that the
app works now and think we should just
shut up just going to give hug your a
little bit of time to respond absolutely
here I'll wait she danced running there
you go
so uh Robin once you go ahead and read
for him if you want yeah sure sure so
kaha I think that it looks great i left
the hollow android style and colors the
current time and lap are easier to read
and understand with the change of
content typography the lamp list
maintains the same look and feel the
analog view and the addition of red and
green values to show this flow as the
fastest laps is a nice touch yeah so so
definitely some of the elements can kind
of be merged in for sure very cool yeah
I mean I think this is this is an app
that really looks great that that does
the basics really really well and I mean
it's just got such a stunning look and
weight and it really does that mean it
is just incredible and remember to you
know a lot of people joke about
skeuomorphism but usually the objections
are that it doesn't add anything or that
it actually makes things ugly or that it
makes things confusing or that's
presenting an interface that people may
not even be familiar with because they
haven't grown up using the original
equipment that the skeuomorph isn't
based on its like none of those apply
here I think that like you said I mean
this is something that I'm really happy
looking at and i would love to explore
more of how to do that sort of thing but
maintain all of the android-navigation
cues and you IQs that that we're used to
in in other apps yeah in general i think
it's it's really interesting to look at
both styles together and see how you can
accomplish the same thing in different
ways yeah absolutely i think this
actually brings up a really good point
that we sort of allude to during the app
clinic quite often which is if you're
going to do something that looks the
same it should work the same but you can
do something totally different and as
long as it looks good that's sweet and
so I think that's what we're kind of
talking about with this app where the
actual timer itself you know all this
stuff here looks fantastic it and it's
intuitive and we've been working on
clock design for a fair number of years
so it is something that people can into
it pretty well it's matter why it looks
that way the things like navigation you
know that's going to be should be
consistent between apps you know you
want to be able to flip between apps and
be able to navigate and
find and discover things really easily
and so that's kind of the sort of
direction you want to take when you're
building an app is try and keep the the
standard things which are going to be
the same as because with a bunch of
other apps should be able to be accessed
and work the same and then things which
are unique to your app make them unique
make them beautiful I'm going to make
just one last comment and that's that
when I hit the set button I think this
is what I was most disappointed with is
that we have a first off this is a less
usable interface than the current and
spinner based interface it but also the
thing that kind of made me sad was we
have some really beautifully designed
buttons but then we also have this which
is you know beautiful in its own way but
jarring next to these and then these
stock buttons that I wish would just go
away forever so in case you guys kind of
see but we've actually got the the set
timer dialogue up which yet is it's
unfortunate it's kind of being
customized in a way that probably made
it look better on gingerbread or froyo
or whatever device that you are built it
on originally but now on a on a jelly
bean device it looks a little dated
really so this is one example where the
dialogue could probably a stop to the
defaults and you'd have a better looking
at yeah i think the the general rule is
that if you're going to use a custom
look and feel make sure that you use
that all the way throughout whatever
view you're modifying because if you
incorporate stock elements into a custom
look and feel then if the stock elements
ever change which of course they do
because a lot of times manufacturers
will put on their own elements etc then
you'll be stuck with elements that they
look out a place and jarring cool are we
I just mentioned that he agrees and he
doesn't want to change the time picker
awesome that's great I mean we're really
looking we're gonna keep an eye on this
one however yeah I think this is an app
which looks great has you know a huge
amount of potential for something which
is already really good so
congratulations thank you for coming on
and and giving us your feedback as well
and yeah keep up the great work we look
forward to seeing where they sent a pens
up absolutely thanks a lot for joining
us hope yet yeah so what well out of
time because we thought this would take
us half an hour and it didn't it's an
open it 45 and we've rushed so maybe in
our next week I'm not sure let's see
let's see what the viewers think let's
say yeah so let us know I'll see if that
hater comes back from last week well
there are some people who don't like fun
and I fear that we may have been smiling
too much so that could be a problem
that's possible but we do love to hear
your feedback and anything we can do
differently better longer shows shorter
show less of us more of someone else I
do let us know we'll try and take that
into account quick heads up because we
do like to advertise our own stuff this
is something that's learned from
watching TV lutely on friday we have the
app clinic once again meaning the way
you got to do it the TV that way then
coming up next second week on android
developer lab this is using one we're
not on TV hahaha so it'll be up on
friday as usual but not as usual it'll
be on at a different time so that's 1030
in the a.m that specific time which is a
UTC minus 7 we're going to try a little
earlier because we found a lot of a lot
of you guys watching us from Europe and
this means you don't have to stay up
past midnight now it may be that our
audience is entirely made up of European
insomniacs in which case we are really
shooting ourselves in the foot here but
we we hope that this means more of you
guys can can watch and take part we're
going to do cameras & photography apps
we've got a bunch of suggestions in the
moderator we're probably going to go out
of this broadcast and start picking the
apps so if you want to make a suggestion
or vote on the ones that are there now
is the time to do it and we'll let you
guys know exactly who we're going to
look at tomorrow later today that's
pretty much it from us we should take
off thanks for watching again let us
know what you think we're going to we
plan to do this show weekly to give all
the developers a chance to let us know
what they think about what we told them
about their apps so I do tune in let us
know what we can do differently on an if
you're watching and you are a developer
make sure that you leave your contact
information for us so absolutely yeah
that's yeah that's how we found all the
guys this week because they are they all
commented in there in the event stream
so i was able to find them
easily absolutely that's not who you
want anyway you were you were i was
doing this hour yeah right oh I'm right
time I'm Ian thank you very much for
watching and we'll see you tomorrow take
care